the switch to underworld i thought was a
kind of a brilliant move you know you
becoming a gun-toting you know superhero
unlikely person yeah did you enjoy
learning martial arts and guns one thing
that worked out and that was a complete
accident that was lucky is a i've got
enormous hands like a man so
it turns out i i'm actually quite good
with guns because i i've got huge hands
so that was lucky and also i don't know
why because i'm a very jumpy person i
can fire guns and not blink which
apparently is unusual
i think i was in such a blind panic that
i kind of forgot how to blink and then
that was how i learned how to do it but
um
yeah so so those were things that sort
of were lucky strokes and then the rest
of it was like a real slog and i i don't
i don't know that i can say i
necessarily enjoyed it because i really
did
feel like oh my god i'm so bad at this
and then i'd watch back on the monitor
and be like huh that actually looks cool
and i still feel like that like to this
day like now people go oh well you're a
seasoned action person and as if i'm
[ __ ] jackie chan or something and i i
still feel just as
um
out of my
sort of comfort zone really and then but
there is a kind of i obviously got
taught quite well because there is kind
of a muscle memory and then it does end
up looking
convincing do you remember scott
speedman's uh name in the movie do you
remember his name
michael michael what corvin right you
want to hear something weird that i
remember from that movie what number was
the house
what number was the house on the address
you've given michael corvin's address
you know you have to find no idea i know
that
why do you
i don't know it's always stayed with me
i've seen the movie like three or four
times it's 5 10. that's his address
5-1-0
that's absolutely insane i just love
that movie and i've seen it enough times
where it kind of stayed in my brain that
his address is 5-1-0
it's incredible just believed i
remembered his name i love at the end
when you slice that vampire's [ __ ]
head in half it's so great because it
was really kind of brilliantly done you
know movies like that can turn out to be
a big mess but well i mean critically i
don't think it went down that well but
people liked it
i loved it i love anything vampire
really
yeah no i don't care what they're
critical everything is vampire and
everything is werewolf and i sort of
feel like i'm very much like the grandma
of all that stuff yeah they were i mean
and they were like you know you know
what's not been done is vampires and
werewolves together and it hadn't and
now if anyone said that i mean it's like
everything it's vampires and werewolves
but at the time it was this like
incredibly like novel
thing